we mentioned at the beginning of the
program here Life is Beautiful is back
in downtown Las Vegas this weekend it's
three days well it's kind of Madness but
it's a lot of fun as well it's on tap
they have seven stages there beautiful
Madness they're beautiful
art and music from famous to up and
coming Candace Charles joining us live
along Fremont East with a sneak peek at
this big event that we've come to love
good morning
good morning Heather I gotta say you
always know what to say I would say
beautiful Madness downtown Las Vegas is
going to be transformed into the arts
and culture festival and we're going to
see performances from Arctic Monkeys as
well as T-Pain I hear Lord as well it's
going to be a star study weekend we got
some rising stars that are going to be
performing on the sage here at Container
Park and I'm joined with the alternative
indie rock band Las Vegas natives sickos
you guys I'm excited to meet you we've
been talking for some time you guys have
some amazing hits you gave me a little
bit of uh The Growlers Vibes you know
Los Growlers as well The Killers I hear
that in some of your music what can
people expect from you guys on your sets
tomorrow at 7 30. so good morning to
everyone that is watching us today uh we
are going to pour our Blood Sweat and
Tears On Stage that's what we're gonna
do we're gonna just bring the energy and
expect to have the best time of our life
lives now I know you guys had some new
music recently coming out right before
the festival too that is really smart
tell us a little bit about that new Zone
yeah so uh Moon we just released it on
um Spotify and uh all other music
streaming platforms
um this is our newest single after our
debut album which was in late April so
this is something long overdue that we
want to give to the fans so uh you know
just show out and support
um and you know capture a set too as
well now does it have the same kind of
filla as like rewind monochrome a little
bit fancy kind of those Beach vibes
um it's a little bit different right but
I think uh one of the great things about
uh about us is we're very diverse right
we we're all influenced by different
bands uh and you know with that we
create our own sound and you know little
by little we try to do things a little
bit different but um you know once you
hear our music you still know it's secos
nice okay now you guys haven't been
together too long 2020 and you're
already here how's it feel to be
performing oh
um I'm super excited I'm pretty sure the
rest of the guys are are hyped up just
you know so this is just a once in a
lifetime experience so um we're really
looking forward to it and uh we're just
gonna have fun and leave it out uh all
on the on the stage awesome thank you
guys so much it was so great meeting you
you guys can catch these guys at 7 30.
it all kicks off tomorrow it's gonna be
a crazy but fun weekend you guys I'll
send it back to you in the studio
thanks Candace love to see that you know
they have so there's seven stages we
were talking about there at life is
beautiful and there's the local artists
sort of stage yes and some of them are
from Las Vegas some of them aren't but a
good portion of them are this is a great
opportunity for them to really highlight
their music when a lot of the focus
might be on some of the bigger some of
the bigger names but you're gonna get
their chance as well and and they're
dressed the part I love that that
sparkly yeah he's ready he's ready to
rock and roll